allah subhanaw taala he says in Chapter
number 19 verse number 31 about Jesus is
what we believe about Jesus in Nina
Jelani Moroccan also an evil soul she
was Jackie madam - hi Happy Valley -
Jung Moo - I assume hi
the lake is of annamaria : hot in
addition him term
Oh little hottie letv him turn
[Laughter]
I am sober Hana so vahana who either
for in
poor Loula who come for your [ __ ] when a
lot be aware of become fa'budun
see welcome
beam me master do me now being the Isis
at jesus according this is guys
Christians
this is what Allah says in the Quran
listen to it tell me if this is not a
better model for you be honest this is
Jesus he says I am the slave of Allah of
God he gave me the book and he made me a
prophet
just like in Chapter 8 of Mark first one
minute left
yes 48 people thought Jesus was a
prophet in the Old Testament and the New
Testament time in the time of Jesus when
he was alive
Jelani mubarak an animal contain he made
me blessed wherever I am this is what we
believe of Jesus he made me blessed
wherever I am you know
well suddenly we saw that he was ducati
madam to higher and he told me to pray
and to give charity so long as I am
Alive you know this is what we believe
about Jesus Christ what Baram validity I
was good with my mother
well I'm at Combe Gibran Jackie I wasn't
that arrogant person
well salam ala yeah you're more willing
to and peace be upon me the day I was
born and the day I die and the day I
will come back to life that is Jesus son
of Mary the one who you didn't take out
is welcome to Louisville hoid on
before we start on